- [Instructor] Let's get some practice.
Simplifying radical expressions
that involve variables.
So let's say I have
two times
the square root of seven x
times three
times the square root of 14 x squared.
Pause the video and see
if you can simplify it.
Taking any perfect squares out
multiplying and taking any perfect squares
out of the radical sign.
Well, let's first
just multiply this thing.
So,
we can change the order of multiplication.
This is going to be the same thing
as two times three
times the square root of seven x
times the square root of 14
x squared.
And so this is going to be equal to
six times
and then the product of two radicals,
you can view that as the
square root of the product.
So six times the square root of
and I'll
actually I'll just leave it like this.
Seven
times
x
and then
let me actually factor 14.
14 is two
times seven
times
x squared.
Actually let me
extend my radical sign a little bit.
And the reason why I
didn't multiply it out.
Obviously we could've
multiplied it in our head.
X times x squared is x to the third.
And we could've said,
seven
times 14 is what
98.
We could've done that.
But when you're trying to factor out
perfect squares, it's actually
easier if it's in this factored form here.
Especially because,
from a variable point of view
you can view this as a
perfect square already.
And then
14's not a perfect square,
seven isn't a perfect square
but seven times seven is.
Seven times seven is a perfect square.
That is 49 of course.
So let's rewrite this a little bit
to see what we can do.
This is going to be six
times
and
I could write it like this.
The square root of
let's put all the perfect squares first
so seven times seven
that is
that's those two.
X squared
x squared
and then
I could
once again separate the two
radicals right over here.
So whatever else is left.
So
I've already used the seven,
the seven, the x squared
I have a two x left.
Times two x.
Hopefully you'll appreciate
that these two things
are equivalent.
I could've put one big radical sign
over 49 x squared times two x
which would've been exactly
what you have there,
but, if you're taking the
radical of the product of things,
that's the same thing as
the product of the radicals.
It's come straight out of
our exponent properties.
But what's valuable about this is
we now see this is six
times
now
we can take the
the square root of 49 x squared
this is going to seven x
square root of 49 is seven
square root of x squared
is going to be x
and then we multiply that
times the square root of two x
and so now we're in the home stretch.
Six times seven is 42 x
times the square root of two x
and the key thing to appreciate is
I keep using this property
that
a radical of products
or the square root of products
is the same thing as a
product of the square root.
So even this step that I did here,
if you wanted, you could've
had an intermediary step.
You could've said that the
square root of 49 x squared
is the same thing
as square root of 49
times the square root of x squared
which would get us square
root of 49 is seven
square root of x squared is x
right over there.
Let's do
let's do another one of these.
So let's say
I have
square root of two a
times
the square root of
14 a to the third
times the square root of five a.
So like always, pause this video
and see if you can
simplify this on your own.
Multiply them and then take
all the perfect squares
out of the radical.
So let's multiply first.
So this is gonna be the same thing
as the square root of
two times 14
times five.
So let me actually just
I'm just going to
two and five are prime.
14 I can factor it as
two times seven
so this is gonna be
two times, instead of
14 I'm going to write
two times seven
and then times five
and then we have a times a to the third
times a
well actually let me write that as
a to the fifth.
We have a to the first,
times a to the third,
times a to the first,
and the exponents you get a to the fifth.
Now, what perfect squares do we have here?
Well we already see a perfect square
in terms of two times two
and then a to the fifth
isn't a perfect square
if you think of terms of the variable a
but you can view that as a
perfect square a to the fourth
times a.
So let's rearrange this a little bit.
And so this is going to be equal to
the square root
of
let me put my perfect squares out front.
The square root of four, two times two
times a to the fourth
and then let me put my non perfect squares
times
I have a seven
a five
and an a that I haven't used yet
so seven times five is 35
so it's 35
a
and now just like we said before,
we could
let me do it
we could say hey look,
this is the same thing as
the square root of four
times the square root of a to the fourth
it's using exponent properties
and then times the square root of
35 a.
Now principle root of
four is positive two.
You can view this as
a positive square root
and then square root of a to the fourth
the principle root is
going to be a squared
and then we're going to have that times
the square root of
35 a
and we're done.
Let's do one more example
and this time, we're going
to involve two variables
which as we'll see
isn't that much more complicating.
So let's simplify
the square root
of 72
x to the third
z to the third
so the key is can we factor
72 is not a perfect square
but is there a perfect
square somewhere in there?
And you immediately see that
if you're trying to factor it
you get 36 times two
and 36 of course is a perfect square.
And likewise x to the
third and z to the third
are not each perfect squares
but they each have an x
squared and z squared in them.
So let me rewrite this.
This is the same thing
This is the same thing as
I can write
let me put all my
perfect squares up front.
So I have 36
I'm gonna take an x squared out
x squared I'm gonna take a z squared out
z squared
and then we're left with
is
we took a 36 out
so we're left with a two times two
and if we took an x squared out of this
we're left with just an x
x to the third divided by x squared is x
two x
and then z to the third
divided by z squared
is just z
and you can verify this
multiply this all out.
You should be getting
you should be getting
exactly what we have here.
I do that little line on
the z to differentiate
so it doesn't look like my twos.
36 times two is 72
x squared times x is x to the third.
Z squared times z is z to the third.
But now this is pretty
straighforward to factor
because
let me just
I'll do more steps than
you would probably do
if you were doing it on your own
but that's because
the whole point here is to learn.
So two
x
z
so that's just using exponent properties.
And so everything here
is a perfect square.
This is going to be the square root of 36
times the square root of x squared
times the square root of z squared
which is going to be square root of 36
is
principle root of 36 is six
principle root of x squared is x
principle root of z squared is z
and we're gonna multiply that
times
square root
of two x
z
and
we are
done.